all right Jesse hi welcome back thank
you welcome back so I interviewed you in
Roman probably a couple years ago at
least gosh wow yeah and then Roman Roman
stopped by recently by himself yep
and he coerced you into coming over yes
well yeah he uh I didn't even know he
did and he just just pulled up the the
the YouTube just recently and showed me
his face and I was like no way because
we had been talking about it for a
little while now
because we ran into a few people who you
had interviewed you guys are still
together yeah yeah on and off I mean um
no we're always on
uh we're in a I mean we're in a
committed
Bond it's a it's a he's my soul mate
it's not
it's not just a relationship that you
can turn on and off you know what I mean
um
it's a
yeah he's my other half
how long you guys been together uh going
on six years now
yeah because I think it's been about
four years since we saw you last
and you had already been together a year
probably about three years yeah it's
been three yeah so it's been yeah so
it's about four five plus years you guys
are both still struggling with your drug
addictions yeah yeah unfortunately I've
been
um addicted to opiates
uh for actually now that I think about
it it's been over half my life really
yeah because I'm 34 right oh you started
so yeah I started really young and um
because of that I uh
yeah I think back on it now and it's
like yeah it's been definitely like over
half my lifespan last time you were here
with Roman you got you were pregnant
right uh yeah we had a little scare not
a scare because it would have been
beautiful but um
yeah it didn't work out
but that's okay
those things have to happen in due time
they have to happen you know there's no
way to
um
plan that kind of thing so if it comes
in it comes if it doesn't yeah so there
was no baby no yeah no that's probably
not the best situation for yeah no
that's not and that's not something that
I'm very um keen on myself
you know what I mean I would I
[Music]
um
I'd rather be
um well established and at least in my
own home so you know because you're
still living on the street yeah but
I live on the street but it's more like
it's a struggle like don't get me wrong
like it really is and you don't know
what it's like until you've really gone
through it yourself and and there's no
way that somebody can you know look at
one another person and say that they
know exactly what they're going through
and why on Earth would you do something
like that or you know why are you
on the street or you know what I mean in
in
it's not just that easy you know what I
mean we we
um
we we we have a solid foundation though
we we have you know good people
surrounding us and and you know not just
friends their family and
you know we have people who look after
us and and we look after them you know
what I mean it becomes more of a
like I said a family it's it's um
we're close it's tight-knit so it's uh
it's better that way you know and and
like I said we've finally set
solid foundation to where you know
he's got his music I've got my
hairdressing and
you know I I love what I do he loves
what he does and you know we just kind
of have to yeah you know get all the way
there we're almost there though it just
takes time it's just that pesky drug
addiction you know it it it I feel like
yeah it is a drug addiction and it does
hold me back it does I'm not gonna lie
like that would be ridiculous to say it
doesn't
but at the same time
um I've been doing it so long Mark like
I honestly like
I I handle it differently I think than
most you know what I mean by that would
you consider yourself functional yeah
yeah I've been it's been a long time
that I've been doing opiates and um
it's something now I think more for
myself is uh
I do them more to feel normal and to
feel like
okay for the day and not sick because it
the withdrawal from that is
one hell of a withdrawal man have you
tried to oh yeah yeah
um I got sober for about nine months
God that was like right before I got
with Roman so like five years ago and
that's the longest out of my
whole drug addiction that I've been
sober
but I like I manage I managed a sober
living I you know I I got so into it
that I I wanted to eventually you know
run my own sober living and
I mean now that I look back on it I I'm
um I'm a people pleaser I think and I'm
really quick to
um
help others before myself you know what
I mean so I thought that by doing that
you know it was going to be the way to
stay clean in the state you know going
on the right path but uh unfortunately I
have really really severe anxieties and
uh
it hinders me big time and that's what
happened I got too much on my plate and
I I relapse but
I don't I don't beat myself up over it
because if I did I would
it would just I would totally spiral and
crash I can't beat myself up over brain
and you transition from heroin to
fentanyl you know
um I know that sounds horrible like and
I'm not the one to like because I don't
believe fennel is any better than heroin
I think it's actually worse
but in my unfortunately in my um
case
I had a heart infection last year
and it's uh it was really really bad I
um
it went from my heart to uh my lungs
because it travels down you know through
your body and it went from my heart to
my lungs to my
kidneys and then to my bladder and I
didn't get to it until it was in my
bladder so I was dying like literally
like
super
dying it was
it was scary bro it was really really
scary how do you get a heart infection
um uh intravenously using yeah so um
it's it's you could be the cleanest
person on the planet and one Speck of
bacteria goes into your skin with the
needle and to your blood and then stops
in the heart
and that's that's what it is
you know what I mean so it could be you
know what I mean it doesn't you know
necessarily get it from being a dirty
person or a you know it's just a
small bacteria that yeah travels there
and it stays there it almost made like
an octopus coming off of my heart valve
yeah so it took four months for them to
clear it so they had to put a stent or I
mean a PICC line straight to my heart
every day for 24 hours a day
um with antibiotics
yeah and then after that because I am an
IV user they didn't want me back out on
the street they uh wanted me to go to a
nursing facility and
unfortunately that didn't work out for
me very well because I went back to the
place where I you know
heavily used drugs
so yeah and that's that's what ended up
happening
I forget from our first interview where
are you from originally uh Thousand Oaks
uh Ventura County yeah inventory and
your family my family well my my mom my
mom went to like 60 different high
schools by the time she graduated and uh
she made it a
a point that she would if if she raised
kids that she was going to keep them in
the same area you know because her
stepfather was a horrible man and
you know made him move constantly so I
can I can say that I I really appreciate
and then and and
super like thankful that she did that
for me you know what I mean because I do
have the same friends that I did then
you know like in high school and whatnot
you know I might not see them very often
but they're still there and they still
give a you know what I mean how do
your friends and family feel about your
current situation
too embarrassed
um at the moment to ask
you know what I mean I think that it's
something that isn't for anybody else to
give me their input on you know what I
mean this is it's it's my life journey
and it's what I'm going through at the
time you know what I mean I don't need
to hear what everybody is thinking about
it you know it's uh I already get I
already beat myself up enough
I don't you know don't really need
others to do that for me you know what I
mean I don't know
I understand where they're coming from
like my my parents will be really happy
to
to know I'm alive right now because I
haven't talked to him for a little while
and I feel horrible horrible for that I
really do
because I'm I'm really close with my
family
but um
you know they don't they don't believe
in my lifestyle and it's not
it's not
I don't think that it's everything that
they think it is you know what I mean I
think it's I think people are very quick
to judge just period in life well it's
easy to look at your situation yeah your
long-term boyfriend has more tattoos on
his face than anyone else yeah and
exactly and a lot of you guys are living
in the street and you're drug addicted
so it's like it's easy to do exactly and
a lot of you know and that's what
society says is not okay
right or I guess but
you know I see I see
not only like do I see him for who he is
but I see through those kind of things
you know I see it for what what it is
and why they did those things or why
they
are in the situations they're in and and
you know how it may made him a better
person really but what do you think
people outside of your circle
don't understand about what you and
Roman are doing what you're going
through
um
yeah I think I just think people have a
misconception of uh
of people who are homeless in general or
or just people who have you know tattoos
or people you know don't do the nine
regular nine to five you know and I
don't either I I'm a hairdresser I do
you know I
I'm My Own Boss you know like
I want to go back to school too and you
know do the same things everybody else
does really you know it's just
yeah I have a habit
you know my habit's just not
uh picking up a glass of wine at the end
of the night you know what I mean to
relax mine's a little different
it's kind of how I feel at least I mean
really when you when you they're very
similar but one is socially acceptable
exactly bro you got it right there
that's 100 what I say all the time
is it socially acceptable
you know just like
one drug is more socially acceptable
than the others like but your drug tends
to put you on the street in a tent
yeah so does so do most I'm not
defending no you're right you're right
wise I think alcohol though for me
because I um I've had to deal with it in
my family your drug is not going to put
you in a head on collision with somebody
yeah and it's also not going to change
me completely when I do it you know what
I mean like alcohol can completely
change a person man like completely and
like scary completely change you
and um I I've just been so spooked from
you know previous experiences with my
family members that like I just I can't
do it it's it scares the out of me
are there addicts in your family oh yeah
my parents are are alcoholics for sure
big time
um you know they used to use like
cocaine and stuff and
yeah my dad used to use a lot of crack
when he was younger and but um yeah
the the alcohol thing
that's their thing and it's just like I
can't get through to him like even if I
try and call and you know it's been a
while it's I get chewed out because you
know they're they've had a few too many
and they want to tell me how they really
feel you know
but normally they wouldn't talk to me
like that or whatever you know what I
mean so that's where we kind of butt
heads
and I understand I really do it's just
um
I just decide not to be around it
anymore
you know what I mean like I just can't
because it's hard
very hard yeah I don't I don't like I
don't like it I don't like alcohol
I don't like really any drug it's like
uh you know I don't I wish I didn't do
the drug I do I really do but
at this point I do it just to feel
normal if you had your life to live all
over again what would you have done
differently uh not much really to be
honest with you
um I've done a lot of cool dude and
I've been a lot of cool places and um
yeah I'm pretty wise for my years and I
I uh I have a lot more to learn and you
know you might as well when you stop
learning you might as well be dead bro
like really
so like that's the biggest thing for me
is to just continue educating myself and
really growing
and and just to strive for
strive to be a better person than I was
yesterday you know what I mean
and um
and uh to to to continue on my journey
for loving myself
and Roman and a of course that's already
a known that's easy what would you say
that's the easy part it's like you know
I gotta like really dig down deep for
the whole like me thing yeah what would
you say are your favorite things about
Roman
what he's taught me that actually to
love myself to like those things
to really sit back and um
see life in a different way
what are you afraid of most
us
um
probably losing him
yeah
losing room yeah
that's one of my bigger bigger fears I
think
oh thank you
yeah sorry
I got pretty far without this uh water
work thing
yeah I'm very known for these tears that
come out of my eyeballs all the time
emotionally what do you go through with
this
I uh I'm a very emotional person
and not only am I emotional like
you know mood-wise but like yeah the
whole tears thing
um
it's a release really to be honest like
I I feel sorry for people who can't cry
you know what I mean
um
I just do it a little more often than I
feel better after you do yeah really I
mean
for me I mean I don't like to be at wuss
or anything but like everyone's like
life is difficult yeah at times exactly
exactly and I can't say or make it out
to be like I'm my mind's any worse than
somebody else's but like yeah I just I
just deal with it a little different and
in a way that I don't think um everybody
understands they're crying is a great
way to yeah
I do it not only do I do it when I'm sad
I do it when I'm happy I do it when I'm
mad I do you know what I mean like it's
it's just a release for my my uh
Spirit really
would you like to have kids one day oh
yeah you would oh yeah yeah I have I
have a we have a cat together right now
and she's everything to me you know so
like yeah I would love to have kids I
really would it's um
always been something I think about
you know but if it doesn't happen it
doesn't happen I'm not
um I'm not one to make
you know Arrangements like that or
something you know what I mean like I
have to plan it out like it's just if
it's something that's meant to be then
it's meant to be right but you've been
in this situation for how long how many
years now in
um on the street yeah
four years
it's been on and off yeah where do you
see yourself in another five years
was established more probably uh
actually in a home or in an apartment or
you know we're about to get into housing
in a little bit now here which is great
so
yeah more established and and and and
more established in my career you know
um like I said I've done I've done hair
for I've been licensed a licensed
hairdresser for over 15 years I love
what I do you know and I do want to get
and being in Hollywood I I do want to
get more into
you know
movie pictures and and that whole scene
so that's something that really does
interest me
I want to get back into school for you
know
computer tech and all weird you
know like music and stuff like that like
I really am interested in all that kind
of stuff as well can you do that with an
opiate addiction hell yeah
hell yeah just um
like I said I I
I've been doing it a long time bro and
um
it's all in how you you know manage
yourself and how you spread yourself out
you can't spread yourself too thin
period
no you're gonna set yourself up for
failure
you know
that's really the way I look at it I
mean I know I know it's hard for me for
people who don't have the addiction to
understand that but
do you have
good memories of your times on the
street
and using drugs yeah and horrible
memories too and I also have horrible
and good memories of being clean and
sober
you know it's just like but is this life
any better or worse than your no it's
just it's exactly the same
you know I mean like I like honestly
like
I had more drama when I was clean and
sober at a sober living than I do now to
be honest yeah
and I can't handle that kind of
I don't do well with that condition to
be honest like yeah I don't
I don't like drama
Jesse what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life ah like I said
um learning to love yourself and to
like I have this thing it's like
something that I like like to to tell
people who have who who are similar to
me in that way where you know you're
people pleasing and and you know helping
others before yourself
but
um
you know when you're in an airplane
and the stewardess is teaching you and
like how to put your seatbelt on where
the exits are and whatnot well when
the oxygen masks come down you know
what's the first thing she says to do
she says to put it on yourself
so that you can help the next person
like your kids or your husband or
whoever it is you know so you you have
to love you before you can really love
it and do
and show other people that too you know
like it's and help other people and
that's a big thing for me like really
because
like I do hair I make people feel
beautiful that's something I love to do
and it gives me
you know love to in order to to make
people feel that way so
yeah but I have to remember that like
yeah it comes from inside I need to you
know remember the mirror like it's
impressive that you're you're able to
maintain this relationship with Roman
for so long oh yeah and it's not easy at
all because people don't want to see us
together for some weird reason they just
don't it must be easier to be together
than alone yeah
I mean especially on the streets
definitely because like it's not a this
is it's not a it's not a walk in the
park like I might you know make it seem
like that sometimes but like that's just
because I've been doing it a long time
it's really not easy at all it's really
hard and that's what's the hardest part
of living in the streets
um
I think that you know I'm more I'm not
in in my familiar area as much like you
know he's known the people around us
more than I have
and sometimes that can be like a barrier
you know because he's been friends with
them a lot longer than I have
but
I'm quick to make friendships and and
show people my integrity and my and my
myself so
if you know I do well I you know I get
by and
the the ones who are supposed to be
around stay around you know and the ones
who aren't definitely
get on quick it can be a real snake pit
it really bad dad
what does Roman say you always says it's
like a snake eating itself
you know what I mean
so
it's true
it's very very tough
but it's that Insanity you know it's
that
it's that
chain it's that expecting different
results like you know what I mean but
but still doing the same thing like you
can't do that that's just not how it
works you know you gotta kind of
throw in the ranchers to somewhere
change it up a little bit you know
all right Jesse thank you so much for
I finally yeah I finally get to have
more of a voice yeah for all those yeah
yeah but like to say I don't have one
well I sure as that one else Roman
got crucified in the comments oh my God
that was horrible that was so horrible
oh God yeah because that was like yeah
even like my whole family like finding
out that I I just want to tell you
people that that has been
one show
Roman's a good dude yeah he's the best
dude I can't even it's nice to hear it I
can't even explain that enough
cool yeah all right Jesse thank you so
much thank you all right